-This is your first time here.
And here we are in New York.
You're from New Jersey, but we
had as Hollywood a meeting
as we could ever have.
We met and we sat at the same
table at the Golden Globes.
-It was so Hollywood.
-It was really Hollywood.
-And we had only been
doing "Brooklyn"
for like a few months.
-And then you guys won.
-And then we won.
-Yeah. And --
-It was very --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That whole night
was so surreal.
And I remember meeting you
so vividly,
because you sat down.
You were talking to
Chelsea Peretti,
and I was just like
"It's cool, it's cool.
It's just Seth Meyers
sitting there.
Just gonna be part of
this conversation.
Oh, you're talking to me? Okay."
-Yeah.
-It was really nice.
And then, I will say, you won --
Because you were very
sweet and nervous,
and then you won and you came
back and you totally iced me.
You changed immediately.
Like, you were totally
big-timing as soon as you won.
-That's my move.
-Yeah. That was your move.
-That's my move. Yeah.
-I'm jealous because you
get to work with
so many wonderful people
on the show,
but especially Andy Samberg,
one of my old friends.
How has your experience been
working with Andy Samberg?
-He's the best.
-He's really the best guy, yeah.
-He's so nice and wonderful.
It's a little annoying.
-I think he's also healthier
now, living in L.A.
and not being on "SNL,"
where we all --
every one of us
who worked at "SNL"
was a lot grumpier,
hung over a lot.
He seems like
green-juiced-out right now.
-He is.
But I really enjoy
when he gets grumpy.
-Yeah, it's pretty funny.
-It happens like once in a while
and it's very similar, like, how
my 3-year-old gets grumpy.
-Yeah. This all tracks
with my experience.
-Yeah, yeah.
It's just kind of like...
But, you know, you just, like,
pour yourself some coffee
and, like, grab a cookie
and just sit near him,
and he will eventually
take that coffee
and eat that cookie, like,
from your hands.
-He does like to be
communal with food...
-Very much so.
-...especially when he
doesn't have any.
-Yes.
-Yeah. It's not like,
"Have a little of mine."
It's like he doesn't have any.
-And he's always trying to be
good and healthy
so he doesn't get sick
and, like,
takes care of himself,
so I really enjoy just, like,
sliding in with
like five cookies.
-Gotcha. As well you should.
This was very exciting.
There were some people who,
when the show got
cancelled over at Fox,
were very vocal
about bringing the show back.
I was a little vocal,
but one of the people who --
-You were very vocal.
-I was very vocal,
but I will say,
the star of it, one of the stars
of it, was Lin-Manuel Miranda,
who then...
[ Cheers and applause ]
His reward was he got to be on
the show and play your brother,
which was fantastic.
How was your experience
with him?
-I have so much love for Lin.
He tweeted about
the show around, like,
the Golden Globes time,
early Season 1,
and I basically ran around set
and I was like,
"Aah! Lin-Manuel Miranda
loves 'Brooklyn.'"
Everybody was like, "Who dat?"
-Yeah.
-Because "Hamilton"
had not come out yet.
And I was like, "Aah!
Los Angeles!"
And then "Hamilton" came out,
and everybody was like,
"Do you know
that Lin-Manuel Miranda
loves 'Brooklyn'?"
I was like...
So, we've been trying for
a really long time
to get him on the show.
And then through the
whole cancelation, all of --
You, Sean Astin --
-Sean Astin, who's been on
the show, as well.
-Who's been on the show.
-Mark Hamill.
We got to get him on.
-Guillermo del Toro.
I was waiting for my call.
-No, no, no.
You've been on the show.
-Well, I have been on the show.
I will say, you know, this is --
Like, Lin got to
go out in person
and, like, wear wardrobe
and have lines.
My cameo was -- I was
a police sketch on the show.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That counts.
-That counts?
-Yeah.
-I have to get the prop, though.
I really do love that
a great deal.
I'm gonna try to
track that down.
-Yeah. It kind of looks like
you and Andy had a baby --
-Yeah.
-That's what that looks like.
-Yeah, we've got
a very similar thing
that we share in common
on our face.
-Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-I'll let you guys decide
which body part.
This is amazing.
You were at NYU.
-Mm-hmm.
-And the day you -- Was it the
day you took your last test,
you got cast in a soap opera?
-Yeah.
-Wow! That's incredible.
-I took my last exam
for college,
and it was, like,
anatomy or something really hard
that I was not sure I
was going to pass.
-Yeah.
-But then I did.
And I walked out
and called my parents.
And I was like, "I'm a graduate.
This is amazing."
And four hours later,
I got the call
that I'd booked a four-year
contract on "One Life to Live."
-Wow! That's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They were probably
just waiting to see
how you did on that
anatomy test.
-Yeah, yeah.
They probably had a plant
in the room,
just like, "Looks like she
knows the answers."
-"She's going to have
the grades, guys."
-"She's gonna have the grades.
She's not gonna have to stay."
-Well, thank you so much
for being here.